er parodiert
interviews mit der deutschen
bundeskanzlerin ein spiel das eben schon
treffen zusammen und probiert vieles aus
alexei baxi alias alexander böhm
deutscher youtube-star diesmal im
einsatz für den youtube kanal einer
elektronik handelskette die nutzlos
bekanntheit um neue produkte zu
vermarkten
wem selbst lebt schon seit zehn jahren
von youtube es gibt eigentlich nichts
großartiges album you tube und da sein
aber die möglichkeiten der plattform
sind das nicht die klassischen
beschränkung hat bei einem verlag
was man noch ein chefredakteur hat er
sagt ja oder nein oder beim sender
man kann mit dem rausgehen was man
selbst so richtig hält ich glaube unsere
generation ist auch von anfang an so
gewohnt einfach mal zu sagen das ist das
was ich zu sagen und zu sagen habe und
das sollte auch so rausgehen youtuber
sollten möglichst gut aussehen und
authentisch sein das ist ihr kapital
wenn sie etwas präsentieren glauben die
user ihren worten ist es da nicht nahe
liegend nur über inhalte zu sprechen die
sich auch gut vermarkten lassen und geld
versprechen das machen natürlich viele
ja ich persönlich weiß nicht ich schaue
dann was mich interessiert gibt es wenn
es einen werbepartner gibt gepokert
aber ich würde trotzdem lustige dinge
ausprobieren banale dinge ausprobieren
ich würde kurzfilme weiterhin
ausprobieren musik wenn sich was ergibt
toll wenn nicht ich mache mein schatz
[Musik]
vormals sich auch von bekannten marken
wie volkswagen bezahlen lassen
in den letzten jahren stecken viele
große unternehmen millionen euro in
deutsche youtuber doch das war zuletzt
schlicht zu viel meinen youtube
vermarkter
ich glaube ehrlich gesagt der
inflationäre gebrauch vom instrument
youtuber marketing wird ein bisschen
zurückgehen einfach weil unternehmen und
auch influenza denen authentizität
verlust vermeiden wollen
das heißt man wird nicht mehr in diesem
youtube video was man sich anschaut
irgendeine versteckt werbebotschaften
oder in der zweiten oder dritten sondern
es wird weniger werden exklusive marken
partnerschaften geschlossen
youtube ist eigentlich etwas für junge
menschen läuft er sich bald die zeit ab
für einen 30-jährigen ich habe ein paar
jahre so gedacht
hätte man nicht vor zwei jahren diese
genau diese frage sagt dann hätte ich
gesagt ja dann müsste mal gucken ob man
möglichst jung bleiben mittlerweile die
leute wachsen mit die weniger wenn man
versucht auf krampf sich irgendwo hin
anzupassen wissen besser ist es auf
seinem kanal bekommt böhm pro
hunderttausend klicks 250 us-dollar von
youtube im monat kommt der
schätzungsweise auf einnahmen von 10.000
us dollar hinzu kommt noch das geld von
werbepartnern
er kann gut davon leben sein ding zu
machen